nucléaire toujours avec la france prié
de donner des informations sur ces
déchets atomiques après ses essais en
algérie dans les années 60 appels de
l'omg campagne internationale qui vient
de publier un rapport intitulé sous le
sable la radioactivité un texte qui
demande à paris je cite de remettre aux
autorités algériennes l'emplacement où
on était enfui enfouir les déchets
contaminés ou alger réclame une étude
sur les risques et transgénérationnelle
17 essais nucléaires ont été effectués
par la france entre 1960 et 1966 écoutez
à ce sujet patrice bouveret un directeur
de l'observatoire de l'armement
il ya huit déjà client et donc des
essais qui ont créé d'énormes quantité
de lave radioactive dans à l'air libre
et puis après l'autre type de déchet
important c'est tout le matériel a été
utilisé pour fait pour faire ces essais
allant du thon vis aux avions qui
traversait la le nuage radioactif pour
pour faire des prélèvements la france
dans les années entre 1960 et 1966 n'a
pas rapatrier ces éléments pour les
traiter comme des déchets nucléaires
dans les centres enfonce mais à creuser
des trous et a enterré tout ce matériel
dans l'ensemble on pense que ce le
désert il ya personne non dans le désert
y ait des populations qui habitent
aucune information n'a été fait à
l'époque mais après non plus les jambes
et qui ceux qui vont dans ces zones là
puisqu'elles sont quasi à l'air libre
peuvent absorber de la radioactivité est
déclenché
des maladies tant de types différents
cancers etc
encore aujourd'hui c'était un plus de 60
ans après